la blague du cameroun c'est génial
ça c'est un pays qui aime le football
[Musique]
aïe
ça a été extraordinaire ouverture de la
can il ya une très grande amélioration
dont les intras us sur sous ton ici dont
on cameron ya je crois qu'il ya six 6
stade et ce sont des impressions à
niveau à niveau mondial
c'est
magnifique tellement magnifique très
beau mais bon pour moi je trouve que
nous avons été mieux organisés ça c'est
clair parce que les études et des roues
les encourager les supporters aller au
stade nous en soirée kdo nous donner des
biens cadeau mais alors réussi à tout ça
qui fait en sorte que l'état soit vide
on à venir pour l'ouverture du premier
match il est à laval est le test pcr à
sa place il a le bac 6 nations sa place
l'ordonnancé parfait c'est parfait trop
d'embouteillages mais très bien faire
c'est bien organisé théâtre en deux les
intrigues en totalité ce very nice
[Musique]